les enfants ils veulent plus de liberté
et plus de respect c'est le résultat
sans surprise d'un sondage que vient
d'effectuer le secrétariat d'état à la
famille auprès d'élèves de 5e et de 6e
alors pour commenter ce sondage est bien
autant demander leur avis aux enfants
eux mêmes
patrick red club et chantal kimmerlin
les enfants ont-ils des droits
aujourd'hui sont ils respectés et
écoutés par les adultes peuvent-ils dès
aujourd'hui faire certaines choses sans
demander l'autorisation par exemple
s'habiller avec les vêtements de leur
choix dépenser leur argent comme bon
leur semble que maman contre un de mes
idées que j'ai changé parce que elle
nous considère comme une égale à elle sa
commune à serrières est dépensé
seulement d'argent je commande de cent
des parents pour le défoncer parce
qu'elle ait concédé par semaine à la
maison les enfants sont punis quand ils
font des bêtises
quelquefois ils sont battus il y à la
gifle l'a fait c'est plus dur encore la
ceinture mais il yad'autres sorte de
punition
privé de télé privée de sortie c'est
donc avec la turquie ne se gêne pas trop
ces cinq autres martyrs recevoir une
gifle ça c'est acceptable mais pas de
vautours être privés de télévision
c'est pas parce que je compare peu trop
trop la télé comment les enfants vivent
l'école se sentent ils responsables
concernés exemple un élève étrangers
fait une grosse faute de français tout à
plat three comment résiste il le
français c'est un peu dur ça c'est dur
et même en français veut faire une faute
peut-être comme ça
normal c'est injuste parce que
être lui dire qu'il a fait une bêtise
c'est tout mais pas de blessés sont
insensibles pas l'injustice
pour moi le pouvoir nazi si ce soit mon
père ma mère donnera haine de la dollar
en poche c'est en même temps c'est très
des joueurs à mon frère et ma soeur
alors que moi je vois rien c'est qu'un
net par rapport à moi chouchoutant
un autre élève